mainly just that we educate them it's
like hey you're moving here for a reason
uh you don't don't don't import your if
you're leaving a state for economic
reasons or political reasons it would
vote don't vote the way you did there
come come to Florida and uh and
understand that policies matter uh the
positions matter the the the reasons why
we do things I served six years in the
legislature before this role I mean the
policy really does matter and and so all
those things the reasons you're moving
here there's reasons behind uh why we're
the success that we are
I'm Dave Rubin and joining me today is
the secretary of state of the Free State
of Florida did you know I like Florida
Corey bird welcome to the Reuben report
oh it's great to be with you Dave thanks
for having me secretary I'm glad to have
you you know I suppose this show has
become kind of a beacon on the internet
of the freedom that we're exporting from
Florida so I thought we could just dive
into kind of all the things that we're
doing right here in Florida will that be
okay with you that'd be perfect love to
talk about all the things that we're
doing in the Free State of Florida great
so look everybody knows obviously
Governor DeSantis and the blueprint we
talk about it a lot here that he's
trying to kind of export to some of the
other states and they they understand
what the chief executive as the governor
does but what actually let's do a little
101 what actually does the Secretary of
State do
sure so um I have an appointed position
which is a little different most
secretaries of state are elected Florida
had an elected secretary until 2002
Catherine Harris of bushby warfane was
our last elected since then it's been an
appointed position so I'm the state's
Chief elections officer the state's
Chief protocol officer so I interact
with foreign governments of state's
Chief Cultural Arts and Cultural officer
historical officer uh do we have the
division of Library resources in the
Department of State and the division of
Corporation so sunbiz you want to start
a business in Florida you come through
me so I I wear many hats
so let's talk about the election stuff
first because when I voted just a couple
months back obviously in the in the
midterms in the gubernatorial election
here having it been my first election in
Florida I can't tell you how thrilled I
was to show my ID to sign something to
walk over with with a volunteer who
clearly showed me where I was going a
piece of paper dropping it in a box it
felt it felt legit and real and that was
in complete stark contrast to what was
going on when I was voting for several
years in Los Angeles California what
have you guys done to tighten up the
election situation here and and is it
basically airtight at this point
sure well I appreciate the opportunity
so I'll give you a little bit of History
so I actually started as a Young
attorney poll Watcher in 1998 I was uh
on in Palm Beach County for Bush V Gore
in 2000 and did some legal work behind
the scenes I spent 12 hours that day
watching people vote and listening to
people openly joke about I go to New
York I voted in New Jersey voting again
here so we've come a long way some when
we were Florida duh and everybody
thought we were terrible at voting
there's really only two counties to
where we are today which is the gold
standard and that's because of the
legislature the last two legislative
sessions and under Governor desantis's
leadership has continuously worked to
improve our elections process to the
point where as you just described it
looks easy but it's because we are doing
this 24 7 365. we're always working on
our elections when you're talking to
counterparts in other states that it's
not going as well I'm not I'm not
talking about crazy California but but
even a more moderate State someone that
either is a secretary area of State
there or is involved in the election
process are they jealous are they asking
you for tips I mean it seems like our
our you know we have a presidential
election coming and I think we're going
to see all of the craziness or questions
that we had last time it doesn't seem
like most of the states have done
anything
right and you mentioned the governor's
blueprint and we are constantly talking
to other states and I was thrilled uh
last week I had a representative from
Wisconsin come down on his own dime to
meet with us and says I want to take
back to Wisconsin what you are doing
here you know teach us show us what
you're doing so uh I I'm always uh
preaching the gospel about what uh what
we're doing and why it works and there's
no reason why other states can adopt uh
the Florida model
yeah so speaking of the Florida model I
mean we can just go through some of the
the greatest hits here but I'm curious
as you've seen uh this Mass influx of
people last I checked it was about 1200
people a day I think almost a million
people in in three years I've asked the
governor this but what what challenges
does that present for the state
um I
namely just that we educate them it's
like hey you're moving here for a reason
uh you don't don't don't import your if
you're leaving a state for economic
reasons or political reasons it would
vote don't vote the way you did there
come come to Florida and uh and
understand that policies matter uh the
positions matter the the the reasons why
we do things I served six years in the
legislature before this role I mean the
policy really does matter and and so all
those things the reasons you're moving
here there's reasons behind uh why we're
the success that we are yeah are you
guys uh shocked at how well it seems to
be working at the moment I mean
obviously there's a super majority in
the house and and the governor's feeling
good after the landslide but just that
it really is happening here I mean
building is happening fast we're fixing
roads you know the aftermath of
Hurricane Ian which watching the rebuild
has just been unbelievable it is it's
exciting um I'm a native Floridian fifth
generation so it's a it's a it's a in my
mind a historic time to be living in
Florida and when I talk to
um foreign governments I mean if we were
our own country we'd be the 16th largest
economy in the world and foreign
governments are excited to come to
Florida you know with Miami being the
gateway to Latin America there's just so
many reasons why there's energy in
Florida
um you know from the governor on down uh
you know great weather uh great natural
resources lots of fun things to do
diverse culture
um and uh it's it it is an exciting time
so when you see the governor getting
into it with Disney and you know the
nonsensical don't quote unquote don't
say gay hb1557
um how does that affect what you're
doing as Secretary of State does it
affect what you're doing at all
it really doesn't uh affect me much I
mean I you know I went from a policy
making role to a policy implementing
role uh just like yesterday the the uh
we rolled out another elections bill
which had its first Hearing in the
Florida Senate uh so I I am engaged on
elections uh lost still uh but as far as
what the legislature is doing and what
the governor's doing uh it really
doesn't impact us all that much
um but certainly supportive and and
voted for those measures when I was in
the house is is anything not working
here when I had Governor DeSantis on
last time just a couple weeks ago I said
look I got to ask you one tough one and
the one tough one seems to be you know
something related to house prices just
because of the influx of people but as
you're looking at it from another office
altogether what are you seeing are the
are the struggles are the are the issues
the stuff that you guys want to fix
still
sure so um I think that uh you it's a
good problem to have that we have so
many new people moving to Florida uh but
I think that balance between uh growth
and and preserving our natural resources
and making sure that we uh are mindful
of all the reasons that we want to live
here from our from our beaches to our
lakes and rivers to water quality and
that's been something that the governor
has championed and I think that's
probably our biggest challenge but I
don't think it's a binary choice where
you can either have you know growth and
terrible environment or a pristine
environment and you know five people
live here uh and so I think that is our
challenge moving forward as a state but
we have the the right people working on
those issues and we'll we'll make it
work I mentioned uh hurricane Ian
earlier uh as you may or may not know my
my folks part-time or down in Sanibel
Island and their places you know still
in in recovery at the moment what's the
job of the Secretary of State when when
a natural disaster like this hits and
and how much coordination do you do or
try to do with the federal government it
sounds like they were kind of they were
kind of good at the beginning maybe cut
and ran a little little bit early but I
don't want to put words in your mouth
that hit right during the election cycle
and uh so I immediately flew down or we
went down there surveyed the damage met
with the supervisors of Elections I mean
some of them they had their own homes
damaged their staff damaged uh polling
places destroyed and we wanted to make
sure that we could pull off an election
so I came back reported to the governor
what our findings are he stepped in
issued an executive order we pulled off
the election and the turnout in those
counties was on par with everywhere else
in the state so it was it was it was so
encouraging when I would when I went
down there and people even though their
their their homes have been devastated
they wanted to vote and they did and
we're very proud of that so we we know
how to step up during a natural disaster
and still preserve the Republic you know
one thing that happened or I guess
didn't happen during Hurricane or the
aftermath was that there there was no
looting you know there was such an
opportunity for looting and crime and
and all kinds of bad stuff and there was
none of it here and that really does
speak to the culture of people here in
Florida well it is I mean the governor
you know we're a Law and Order state the
law means something and
and you know the the election code and
for so long for whatever reason people
think ah it's elections law doesn't
really matter it's not in force it's a
wink and a nod it's okay if you vote
twice nobody's going to catch you
Governor said no we're creating an
office of election crimes and security
we're going to enforce our election code
and I think that only does that deter
the Bad actors but it gives confidence
to the the law-abiding citizen that that
their vote's going to count so whether
it's election law whether it's our
unfortunately our criminal laws there's
a clear message in Florida that that our
laws mean something they're going to be
enforced and don't break them well
they're going to be consequences
uh staying on the election thing for
just a second I know we jumped off there
but just jumping back on that a second
so in in states with letter Democrat run
that clearly don't want some of these
policies put in place what would you say
to just the Republican citizen who is
there related to what they can do I know
we talked about what maybe another
Secretary of State that's a friendly can
do right well the governor has said in
in states you have to use the laws that
are in your state and and and Fight Fire
with Fire so you know we're against
ballot harvesting we've made that
illegal in Florida but if ballot
harvesting is illegal in your state then
you have to use the law where you are
because unless you get into the
positions of power whether it's Governor
or Supreme Court or legislature you're
not going to be able to effectuate the
change so I would encourage those
individuals get involved stay involved
we look at what happened in Virginia
Virginia is a blue State they elect
Glenn Junkin because I know many of the
people who got engaged and were at the
polling places and it's it's long it's
boring work I've done it but it is
critical critical to to winning and
that's what I would tell them to do yeah
are you seeing more and more parents get
involved in education down here I mean
it seems like that really was the the
instigator I think I I saw you speak at
the at one of the blueprint events a
couple months ago I know I did and and
it you know that was about parents just
getting on school boards and the
governor was going around the room and
he seemed to know every County what was
happening in every single election who
was getting on who the superintendents
were Etc
it's been great and it's empowering
parents uh the governor appointed my
wife to the State Board of Education and
she she is the the voice of the the
parents I mean we're we're parents we
have a a young family and uh it gives
people encouragement that they they have
a voice that they're being listened to
from the governor on down to the local
school boards that uh being a citizen I
always preach this being a citizen
requires active engagement it's not an
activity where you sit back and wait for
things to happen you got to get your
hands dirty and get involved and you
have that opportunity in Florida
are you guys ever worried that you know
the more we do it right here in Florida
the more that that Focus turns to us and
that that could be a problem you know
that the federal government basically
which is seemingly screwing up so many
things that at some point it's like they
keep looking to Florida going man
they're they're doing basically the
opposite of everything we do it's
working
you know we we are still in the United
States uh and that that's a an issue
there
right well you know we're gonna have
three Statewide elections in 2024 uh my
mind is already there I'm already
working on that I know we're going to
get a lot of attention in Florida for a
whole host of reasons but I always go
back to it's it's the genius of the
founders that they gave us a federal
system meaning federalism where the
States can be 50 Laboratories of
experiment we're we're showing what's
what's right about America you know I'll
battle it compare us to California and
New York and Illinois any day of the
week and I think it gives people in
those States hope that we're not lost we
can do this if the right people and the
right policies are put in place are you
ever worried that we could tip too far
red is there such a thing as too far red
I mean we're accomplishing an awful lot
but you know that that there would
somehow be no balance I'm actually just
throwing it out there I I probably don't
sure don't think so myself I I think a
lot of about that but I I
at some point we're
interstates be blue States and red
States be red States and we're going to
have to be okay with that
um and you know the Supreme Court said
that in Dobbs I mean listen abortion's
not a state a federal issue it's a state
issue but that means states are going to
do things differently and then people
are going to vote with their feet you
said 1200 a day are moving to Florida
and I tell people it's like they're
voting with their their feet they're
moving here
um and that is an expression of their
their opinion we're gaining people the
blue states are losing people
um so I think that's an encouraging sign
that we stood and that keeps that that
keep that that's a pressure valve it it
keeps things from getting too too far
too far um into Crazy Land so I think
when people think of Florida they think
okay we're leading you know obviously we
LED on on fighting covid lockdowns and
mandates and that that sort of insanity
I see I think they see we're leading on
education which now seems to be exported
to Iowa and Arkansas and some of these
other states what else do you think
we're leading on at the moment when the
governor talks about that blueprint
oh yeah just on on on
um economic policies I mean you know our
um new business startups I mean we we
can hardly keep up with all of the new
business startups in Florida
um we're we're leading I mean you know
the governor just signed a
constitutional carry so we became the
26th state to do that and my background
is as a Second Amendment Firearms law
attorney that that's what I did so
um you know on on so many issues of
Freedom so whether it's elections
whether it's business startups education
we really are we we're leading on so on
just about everything yeah it's
interesting too because you know I'm
down here in Miami where obviously it's
growing so fast and we're kind of
running out of room here but you know
when I've flown up to Tallahassee a
couple of times you realize there
there's actually plenty of room to still
build in Florida I mean we've got a lot
of land that I think can be uh you know
bring in some new people and start
building some new communities we do so
when I was in the legislature I
represented I'm from the Jacksonville
area and Nassau County the furthest
Northeast part of the state and there's
lots of land that it's growing and that
brings challenges some of the people
that have been there a while
um uh you know they don't always like
all the new growth but there is plenty
of land plenty plenty of room to grow
and we just have to do a smart you know
smart growth is is is a good thing um I
actually I grew up in Miami so I've seen
the changes there from the 70s and 80s
to today and it's a wonderful place but
you are kind of constricted between the
the the coast and and the Everglades uh
but then there's plenty of places in
Florida we have room to grow
you know the governor has been uh
obviously talking a lot about ESG and
figuring out a way that we can have some
of our the state's money less invested
with these companies that are focused on
diversity Equity inclusion does that
involve any of your day-to-day
operations
it really doesn't uh we're we're
ministerial when it comes to
um starting new businesses I mean if
they file the right paperwork uh they do
that so the the cfo's um office Jimmy
Patronus the the ESG stuff mainly comes
more through the Chief Financial Officer
but certainly you know whether it's the
legislature having the power of the
purse whether it's the universities and
saying no listen we're spending taxpayer
dollars we call the shots you don't make
the policies or whether it's uh ESG and
corporations we do have the power of the
person and we're exercising it so one of
the things we talk about on the show a
lot is that there seems to be this this
kind of Divergence amongst Republicans
right now like either we will just be
small government Republicans and never
use the levers of government to do
anything or as I think we're doing it
more so in Florida we'd prefer not to
use the government all the time but
we're going to figure out the moments to
do so do you guys talk about that like
when we can just kind of let things be
versus those moments that we actually do
have to fight back I would say you know
going after Disney might be one of those
moments sure no I mean we uh the
I would always talk about the why why
are we do
we do slate in a vacuum it all starts
from the foundation of the Constitution
and all of our powers and authority of
the government and the laws flow from
that so if we are operating within those
constitutional bounds then the
government has the authority I mean the
founders talked about ordered Liberty
well order requires some some form of
agreed upon standards that we're all
good uh that the the community a state
is going to live under and so I don't
think it's uh you know the the small
government necessarily you know um you
know hard libertarian view that the
government can never be involved in
anything that's just you're just seeding
the seating the power of your opponents
are you shocked when you see some of the
mainstream media reaction to what's
going on in Florida I mean I basically
I'm covering it every day the things
they say about the governor and about
Florida and what's going on here you
know that where This Racist homophobic
backward State and it's like everyone
that's in this room with me right now
these are all Cali transplants every you
know I spend so much time every day
saying hi to people at stores who are
just moving here everybody's happy and
free and smiley I I go to New York
everybody looks miserable I was in DC
last week I mean everybody's just just
had it and here it's just uh it's just
smiles and sunshine it is it's different
and uh it is amazing when I read what's
in the mainstream media I mean I when I
read about things that the words they
put in my mouth things that I've never
said uh they don't listen we put out
press releases all the time about people
registering to vote and getting you know
get engaged make sure all of your
information is up to date and all I do
is get called a you know a vote voter
suppressionist and all we're trying to
do is prevent certain types of people
from voting and uh so it's a little
frustrating but it's the environment we
live in and I just always point back to
you know if we're if we're if we're
putting points on the board for the
people they will be our best Messengers
and and like you said people are happy
they're smiling the the state is growing
and uh the proof is in the pudding uh
you mentioned the concealed carry so
that just went went into effect I think
was that yesterday literally
the governor signed it into law on
Monday I believe it goes into effect
July 1. July 1st okay so I mean in
essence this is just permitless carry so
that that is that really what the fight
was about whether there should be
permits or not as opposed to the
concealed carry in and of itself correct
so since uh since the mid 80s the law in
Florida was that you had to have a a
permit a license from the state in order
to carry a concealed firearm outside of
the home and uh you know the decision
was made and I agree with that 100 you
shouldn't need a permission slip from
the government to exercise a
constitutional right and I would always
tell people my colleagues the bad guys
don't follow the law anyway criminals by
definition don't follow the law so all
we were doing was burdening law-abiding
citizens and now we've given them that
opportunity to defend themselves so when
they're outside the home without a
permission slip from the government uh
speaking of defend defending themselves
you know obviously having in the last
two weeks this this shooting in
Tennessee and you know there have been
over the course of years a few shootings
obviously the Orlando Pulse Nightclub
one and the Parkland outside of Orlando
shooting at the school there
um is what are we doing in terms of that
what what can the state do is that up to
the cities who decides what's what's
happening in terms of security of
schools sure so um in Florida we have a
very robust preemption law so all
firearms regulations
um are at the state level there's none
at the local or or at the local level so
after the Parkland uh um shooting uh the
state stepped up and appropriated
millions of dollars for for school
security and to put in robust
enhancements
um which so that that's happening at the
state level they're very aggressive to
ensure that uh that our schools are
secure I I haven't I have an
eight-year-old daughter I mean I think
about this every single day but when you
live in a in a constitutional republic
you have to balance constitutional
rights
um with with liberty and freedom and
safety and security also you put
everybody in prison we can have the
safest country in the world but that's
not uh it's not the road we're going
down and every one of these is tragic
but what I look at is you know why are
it's not the guns the guns have been
prevalent in America we used to be able
to order guns through the Sears catalog
uh well you can't do that anymore so
there's something fundamentally wrong
with our culture and that's where we
need to be focusing on and fixing and
mental health and we're doing all of
those things in Florida yeah are we
doing anything on the mental health side
you know I'm always kind of like when I
go to back to Cali you know you go to
Los Angeles every other billboard is for
California mental health this or that
and it always seems sort of I mean it
seems Darkly humorous to me like as if
the state of California is going to be
able to help anyone's mental health but
but what do you think the role of the
state is for that right I mean we should
have resources available for people we
shouldn't stigmatize it we should make
people say if you have or having an
issue they they uh
um they should seek help and we should
help where we need to I mean people need
Financial Resources the station should
step up but I think it goes back to two
you know the way we raise our children
and you know my parents taught me at an
early age life isn't fair deal with it
early
um and and we're we've we're so
protecting our children that we're
insulating them from any type of uh of
of
uh Misfortune when they're children so
they they haven't learned the coping
skills and so when you become an adult
and life gets really hard and you've
never been told no in your life or had
to deal with any adversity I can
understand why people break and and uh
but I don't know that Government Can can
fix parenting other than emphasizing and
fostering a state and an environment
that we emphasize the role of parenting
and families and their nurturing role in
preparing young people to become
citizens
is there anything else we should cover
here you know I keep saying the main
thing that I think California or that
Florida is exporting right now is
competency that it it just it feels like
we have the right people in charge who
are balancing that blend of when you use
the government when you don't how you
actually spend properly where you want
to apply the law Etc and that's just
kind of working so did I did I miss
anything here no and I'm glad you raised
the point of Competency because I think
uh what I see in in DC and there there's
a lot of people who get into politics
it's just celebrity by another means and
they think it's about the tweeting and
getting on TV but actually the
day-to-day the mundane job of actually
government governing and making sure
that
um our elections are working that you
can go file a corporation that takes
work it takes competency I have an
amazing staff of people who come to work
every single day uh some of those
nameless faceless bureaucrats that we
talk about but they do a wonderful job
and that's what I would emphasize it to
your point that that competency matters
I think the governor's talked about that
that he's he puts people in place that
he can trust to go run an agency and
make sure that we're delivering for the
people of Florida every single day and
if we're not doing that he's going to
take us out he's going to remove us and
put somebody in who can and uh I I think
that's a testament to his leadership
secretary probably not the most
difficult interview he ever did but I'm
just happy to amplify all the goodness
out of Florida because it literally
changed my life so appreciate your time
like I said I'm a huge fan and it's been
an honor
for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics instead of
mindless dribble check out our politics
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics watch
our full episode playlist all right over
here and to get notified of all future
videos be sure to subscribe and click
the notification Bell